ahora sí vamos a entrar a la
demostración y en el último vídeo
dijimos que si podíamos ver que cada
sumando era igual a su correspondiente
entonces esencialmente habríamos
terminado la demostración lo que
teníamos en amarillo era simplemente una
expresión de lo que es el flujo el flujo
a través de la superficie del campo
vectorial y lo que está en verde esto
que está en verde es la integral de la
divergencia de f
la integral triple a lo largo de nuestra
región r lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo y probablemente en el siguiente es
demostrar que estos son equivalentes
estos dos estas dos de estas dos
expresiones son equivalentes
esencialmente es lo mismo y lo voy a
hacer usando el hecho de que la región
es simple y sólida en particular que es
de tipo 1
ok entonces voy a utilizar que es de
tipo 1 para demostrar esta equivalencia
pueden usar los mismos argumentos para
demostrar que los otros también son
equivalentes por ejemplo para estos este
par se utiliza que es de tipo
y para demostrar que estos dos son
equivalentes se utiliza que es de tipo 3
entonces voy a pasar a probar el último
y les quedará a todos ustedes probar los
dos primeros entonces antes que nada
vamos a bajar un poco y vamos a recordar
vamos a recordar que es una región de
tipo 1 porque una región de tipo 1 una
región de tipo 1 que digamos sea r es
simplemente un conjunto de ternas de
puntos en el espacio x y z tales que
necesitamos que la pareja xy es decir
como punto se encuentre en cierto
dominio
y además vamos a necesitar que nuestra
variable zeta se encuentre acotada por
dos funciones digamos que la inferior
sea f 1 de x
es decir que z sea mayor o igual que
esto pero al mismo tiempo sea menor o
igual que otra función que vamos a
llamarle f 2 de x y muy bien entonces
vamos a cerrar este conjunto ok vamos a
hacer un dibujo rápidamente de más o
menos cómo se ven las regiones tipo 1
para ir recordando por ejemplo si aquí
tenemos los ejes
y más o menos derecho este es el eje
zeta
el eje y fin
el eje x ok quedaron ahí los ejes vamos
a dibujar entonces un dominio para los
puntos x
aquí vamos a tener cierto dominio que
éste es el que le vamos a llamar el
dominio de sí queda claro que estos es
los puntos el dominio de se encuentra
contenido en el plano xy aquí son sólo
puntos de la forma x coma ya y ahora
vamos a tener dos funciones que
esencialmente las funciones las podemos
ver como gráficas entonces por ejemplo
tenemos nuestra función f 1 que quien
sabe como sea pero ahí la tenemos
ok podemos verla como una superficie
como una gráfica de una función y
también vamos a tener deber de nuestra
función f 2 quien sabe cómo se ve más o
menos podría ser de esta forma esta es
nuestra función f 2 ok déjenme déjenme
quitarlos estorbar más de lo que quiero
ok y ahora tenemos que nuestra nuestra
variable zeta se puede mover a lo largo
de todo esto de estos posibles valores
dados por las funciones entonces nuestra
variable zeta
va a mover en esta especie de cilindro
que no necesariamente se debe ver como
un cilindro pero pero al menos esto
ejemplo ejemplifica efe expertos
ejemplifica muy bien lo que quiero decir
con las regiones de tres dimensiones de
tipo 1 aunque esta es una muy buena idea
de lo que es una región de tipo 1
pueden variar las formas por supuesto
pero lo importante es que como vamos a
querer calcular una integral de
superficie es decir vamos a calcular la
integral de superficie de la función r
pues necesitamos partir esta región
entre superficies y esencialmente está
dada por tres esta de aquí arriba que
vamos a llamar la s 2 podemos tomar esta
de aquí abajo que le podemos llamar s 1
y podemos tomar esta que es digamos como
la parte lateral de la región que la
vamos a llamar s 3 ok s1 y s2 son como
las tapas y s13 es como el cuerpo de una
especie como de cilindro en este caso
entonces qué es lo que ocurre vamos a
tener que calcular la integral de
superficie
la integral de superficie de r que
multiplica a cada punto n como esta
superficie la pudimos partir en tres
distintas entonces vamos a escribir esta
integral como tres sumas por ejemplo la
primera que es la integral sobre ese dos
de r de cada punto n de s aquí por
supuesto que me falta un bs
déjenme déjenme ver si lo puedo acomodar
bien aquí va de ese debe ser igual a
este primer sumando y ahora vamos a
sumar también la integral de superficies
sobre esta superficie ese 1 entonces
vamos a tener la integral sobre ese 1 de
r por cada punto n de s
y vamos a final al final vamos a sumar
la integral sobre ese 3 de r por cada
punto n de s muy bien que es lo
importante de haber descompuesto de esta
forma vamos a fijarnos precisamente en
ese 3 aquí como se mueve el vector
normal pueden ir apuntando así de esta
forma siempre siempre de esta forma lo
importante de los vectores normales en
ese 3 es que no tienen ninguna
inclinación hacia arriba o hacia abajo
es decir se mantienen paralelos al plano
xy entonces cada punto n lo que nos
pedía era la magnitud de en la
componente zeta del vector normal
unitario pero si no tiene ninguna
componente zeta quiere decir que cada
punto n déjenme incluso escribirlo
quiere decir que cada punto n al menos
en ese 3 vale 0 y por lo tanto toda esta
parte todas
toda esta integral la podemos suprimir o
eliminar entonces esto se simplifica
simplemente a dos únicos sumandos en el
próximo vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es re
expresar todo esto en términos de
integrales dobles sobre el dominio de
vamos a tratar de evaluar estas
integrales de superficie y llegar a la
al resultado de que debe ser igual a la
integral sobre nuestra región r de la
parcial de la función r respecto de z